watch afterwards sunday night at 9
eastern on c-span 2's book tv
this year marks the 325th anniversary of
the salem witch trials up next on
american history tv author and salem
state university professor emerson baker
provides an in-depth look at the history
of salem he explores how it went from a
simple town in massachusetts in 1692 to
a city synonymous with witchcraft and
tragedy this hour-long presentation was
part of an all-day symposium held at
salem state university in massachusetts
good morning everybody
it's lovely to see you all today on this
this day this reverent day
my name is donna seeger i'm chair of the
history department here at salem state
university
um i thank you all for coming today
uh
we're all here obviously uh because of
bridget bishop
and her fellow victims of
1692 the long hot summer and early fall
of 1692.
this is the 325th anniversary of those
events
as a history professor i am sometimes
reticent to indulge in what i call
anniversary history
because i like my students to think that
every single day is historic
but it does feel right to take take a
moment take a day
and really think about what happened
um during that year so that's what we're
doing
today um
that's what the city of salem is going
to be doing probably all summer long
um before i introduce um
our distinguished guest who's going to
open up our symposium the mayor of salem
kimberly driscoll i just want to say
thanks before i forget to thank
everybody at the end while we are
wrapping up this day i'm going to thank
all of the presenters for their
contributions but right now i just want
to thank my little committee
uh because we have been working on this
for a year
and uh and that would include uh the two
women downstairs who are not going to
hear my thanks beth behringer and
meredith george from essex heritage
national area
uh also from the salem award foundation
we have shelby hypes who has a brief
announcement to make right here about
our special feature
if you are a descendant of somebody
connected with the trials and would like
to participate in a very brief informal
video interview and have not signed up i
have the sheet
and please see me that's it thanks
we also want to thank elizabeth peterson
from the witch house and my colleague
tad baker who is going to be speaking to
you shortly
who's my colleague for a few more days
in the salem state history department to
talk about that more later
so without further ado now i would like
to introduce the mayor of salem
kimberly driscoll for brief opening
remarks
[Applause]
thank you professor vincent and thank
you to everyone whose attendance it
really um for those of us who live in
salem feel like we have an extra
responsibility and by having a packed
room on a beautiful saturday to talk
about the salem witch trials and what it
means to our community indeed i think
speaks to both the events that took
place that time and how much people
still reflect on them today
in salem we are always moving forward
but never without reflecting on the road
by which we came here
the examples of our past
the examples of our past are generations
who push the boundaries to innovate and
build a thriving community that values
progress and growth
from the settlers who laid out
foundations to the visionaries of the
maritime trade that made salem famous
around the world
from the entrepreneurs who built our
industrial manufacturing base and to the
workers in those factories who pushed
back when conditions were unfair or
dangerous
from those who steadfastly rebuilt the
city after the devastating fire of 1914
to the preservationist who saved it from
a different kind of devastation during
the urban renewal movement
and yes of course from the tragic
lessons we learned collectively from
1692 as well
it was on that day
in on that on this day in that year 325
years ago to the day that bridget's
bishop would become the first of many
innocents to lose their lives that year
today i should say earlier this week we
officially announced that we'll gather
to dedicate our newest memorial to honor
the memory of those who were unjustly
executed in 1692. on july 19th at noon
we'll gather at proctor's ledge the site
of the executions to dedicate a memorial
on that site
325 years after the first of three
mass executions took place at the site
when five individuals were hanged
sarah goode
elizabeth howe
susanna martin rebecca nurse and sarah
wiles
i hope many of you in this room will be
able to join us as we honor their memory
and pledge to never forget the lessons
of the salem witch trials namely to
never allow prejudice to conquer reason
and fear to overcome courage
salem is a special place because we
value that history
every person who lives here is imbued uh
with that history and whether or not
they're a family that traces their
lineage back generations or whether
they're newly arrived
we feel those of us living in salem it
is indeed our responsibility 325 years
later to ensure that as we move forward
as a community we do so in a manner that
reminds all of the legacies and the
lessons of the witch trials and it
really is our duty to promote awareness
understanding and empathy and support of
human rights tolerance and social
justice
we're so fortunate to have partners both
those here at this symposium
looking forward to hearing ted again and
and learning from all of the work that
he's done and professor vincent and her
team here who continues to make sure
that the history this important history
is not lost on anybody in our community
and those that pass through here
tomorrow we'll be fortunate to join
members of the salem award foundation
yet again at the site of our tri
centenary memorial to keep in mind these
lessons and today more than ever in our
community and frankly across this
country these are vital lessons that we
need to make sure the next generation
understands and hears in this place like
salem that prides itself on our history
while also having witches as a mascot
and on our police car it's a it's a
balance right um
and um
i think this part of this history um
it's important for us to remember and
pass on to the next generations and to
continue to fight um the the fear and
the hatred that can overcome a small
community like salem or a large country
like the united states so thanks for
being here to learn more about it and
thank you to professor vincent and her
team for putting this together
mayor driscoll is an old friend of mine
so she's referring to me by my former
name
[Laughter]
and now i've embarrassed her
[Laughter]
um so without for further ado i want to
introduce you my colleague emerson tad
baker who i think you all agree with me
is the expert
on the sandwich trials following the
publication of his masterful book a
storm of witchcraft
and we are so lucky to have him to give
us an overview
it takes
a real master of the craft to be able to
present an overview i i'm really
struggling
he told me
so hard to just do an overview of salem
witch trials
in in an hour and i said tell me about
it i've got to do all of europe
[Laughter]
so i don't i i don't feel that sorry for
him really
[Laughter]
and i'm sure he will do a great job
uh tad has been my colleague and my
friend for over 20 years probably well
over 20 years but let's call it 20 years
um and i'm i'm i'm kind of uh sad to to
to introduce him today because i'm
hoping this is not his academic swan
song no he's not dying it's not that bad
he's going to become the interim dean of
graduate studies here at salem state
university
[Applause]
i hope in that important position he
will have time to continue his
scholarship because he is our expert
so without further ado tab
thanks donna
um
you're being way too kind though
honestly because there really are
so many experts on the salem witch
trials and i never could have done my
work
without their work and um honestly uh
it's
it's wonderful that some of them are be
here to be here today and you'll hear
from them as well uh margot burns
marilyn roach and a host of others
so yeah
how do we do this in the in an hour um
well i want to explore a couple of some
general points but also a couple of
themes we'll keep on coming back to i
really want to talk about uh
really politics and religion which i
think are sort of overlooked aspects of
the witch trials which seems hard to
believe considering that witchcraft is
really a religious crime and that also
trials by the very definition or
political acts but so we're going to
keep on sort of circling back to that
point because i think it's incredibly
relevant
uh frankly today and uh
at the same time i like to start out by
pointing out that
salem is is far from unique you know
almost
every culture under the sun past present
and probably unfortunately future has
their versions of witch hunts
has their versions of witches
and we have to look no further than you
know donna you're right you have a lot
more witches to deal with in europe you
know
during the during the great age
[Laughter]
there were no witches you're absolutely
right but at the same time when you
write a book and you're given you can't
constantly be putting everything in
quotes right so i will i will refer to
people as witches but please assume that
i'm doing this
um
accused of being witches right anyhow
you know during during the great age of
witch hunts in europe about a hundred
thousand people are accused and about
half of them are executed and there are
so many
that we really don't know the numbers we
certainly don't know all the names um
biggest outbreak in cologne over a
10-year period about 2 000 people died
and
they continue into the 18th century and
hungary alone about 800 people die in
the 18th century from witch trials uh so
salem is not the biggest it's certainly
not the last
and in fact yes some would say that
we're still having witch hunts right
there they're in the news
pretty much
every day
and
uh you know it all politicians of all
stripes forever refer to salem and witch
hunts
the first
reference making fun of salem for the
witch hunts was published in london in
1697.
it really hasn't stopped since
and
as i say every party every politician
last year of course it was the benghazi
witch hunts for example right so uh it's
a frame of reference that we've come to
take and we all know that in many ways
it's synonymous for salem and i guess
the
here's the thing
in salem we have this this thing that is
the
by far the largest outbreak of
witchcraft in american history
at least 172 people are accused of
witchcraft there could be more we don't
know is as margot will we'll tell you a
little bit later we have almost a
thousand surviving documents from the
salem trials honestly i think one reason
we know so much about salem is because
it is so well documented right
um
but having said that there's a lot of
documents that don't survive um
we know that 156 people have have legal
proceedings that do survive we do know
of course that 19 were executed starting
on this day in 1692 one pressed to death
and at least five died in jail there
might have been a sixth we're not
entirely certain so by european
standards though folks this is
unfortunately a fly spec and i mean that
with all due respect and we'll even
point out that one of those people who
died in jail roger toothacher was a
distant relative of mine so uh by the
same time you know to hang 19 people for
witchcraft
uh was a all too common event in europe
so that raises the question doesn't it
is to
uh why isn't cologne the witch city you
know i've been there it's a lovely
cathedral nice people no one even
mentioned the fact you wouldn't know the
fact that there were witch trials there
um why is salem and salem alone
synonymous with witch hunt uh with
scapegoating rushing to judgment
fanaticism extremism right why salem
so i want to sort of explore that a
little bit about today
and talk about how we try to explain the
events of 1692
and how do we explain witch hunts and
again really to talk a little bit about
maybe sort of those those factors
particularly those sort of religious and
political factors that lead to witch
hunts past present and unfortunately
future
salem has a really kind of unique place
in american history and that was that
was cemented long before
the the witch trials
salem
is one of the first settlements in new
england
it is
originally the fishing village of nom
keeg the native american word for
fishing place
in 1629 the settlers here very
idealistic uh puritan folk changed the
name to jerusalem or salem
is it shortened for the city of peace
right
so from the start it is meant to be this
beautiful christian place this holy city
john winthrop arrives with the winthrop
fleet in 1630 first coming into salem
why because salem is older than boston
they hadn't created boston yet salem was
the first settlement of the colony salem
is where it all starts
and sometime in that process of sailing
over or arrival or shortly afterwards of
course winthrop gives his very famous
sermon a model of christian charity
which in it has the famous words we
shall be as a city upon a hill and the
eyes of the world are upon us
in many ways then salem is that city
upon the hill right it is that shining
example
metaphorically physically this is it
this is the start of the puritan
experiment in massachusetts bay
it is supposed to be a place where where
people walk hand in hand with each other
and with god and live in peace and
harmony
and i think maybe that's part of the
answer as to why we remember the salem
witch trials and why we will never
forget them because
think of this tremendous fall from grace
from this ideal of 1630 1692
62 years later while people who were
still alive who heard winthrop give that
sermon
daughters are accusing mothers neighbors
are accusing neighbors of being witches
and the colony the puritan experiment is
being torn apart
and i think that's a trauma we never
quite recovered from
in many ways it's really a turning point
in american history it's
in some ways i see it as the beginning
of the end of puritanism in new england
and frankly it's the beginning of
something much deeper and that is our
distrust of government if you think last
year's elections
were an indication of something new in
america i would tell you it is a very
old impulse this sort of libertarian
anti-government streak that manifests
itself again throughout american
politics
i think it really begins
in some ways in 1692 with the first
massive failure of the government to
protect the lives of the innocent
and then frankly to try to cover up the
fact
and people from the get-go refused to
let it be forgotten descendants of the
victims petitioned the massachusetts
legislature for over the next 50 years
seeking redress of grievance seeking
pardons for the victims
people here have never forgotten that
and indeed never will
so what caused it
well
shameless plug for my book i call my
book
a storm of witchcraft
because it really took a perfect storm
of forces
to create even what was in america a
large outbreak of witchcraft to have all
something horrible happen you have to
have many things come together and in
this case there are a lot of factors and
i want to run through them briefly but
just to outline them
factionalism in salem village
but really colony-wide political
instability uh the perceived decline of
puritanism
the worst most extreme weather of the
little ice age inflation high taxes
economic failure military disaster if it
sounds like the four horsemen of the
apocalypse folks is pretty close right
this was a grim time for a people to go
through
now in large part though the focus of
action really begins
in just one part of that colony and that
is salem village
salem village
is now actually the town of danvers
but in 1692 it was what it was part of
shall we say a super-sized salem which
included a number of present-day towns
salem peabody danvers middleton
it's a huge area where some people
actually could be up to 12 miles away
from the meeting house and be expected
to attend worship there in downtown what
is now downtown salem on the sabbath
so ironically on the puritan on the
lord's day of rest uh you're expected to
spend half the day trying to get into
church imagine trying to do that in a
blizzard in february right um
so people in outlying areas like say
like like salem village had been trying
to achieve their independence and be
able to hire their own minister uh to
break off from salem and salem had
allowed a number of communities to do
this in including beverly
in wynnum and manchester uh but they
were reluctant to let salem village go
for a number of reasons but finally in
1672 salem village is granted parish
status and it's kind of this
quasi-freedom
they're allowed to use their tax money
to hire a minister but they really don't
have political control over the
community and that creates all sorts of
trouble and factions to the point where
by 1692 of course they are on their
fourth minister in 20 years and that man
is very famous reverend samuel paris a
very contentious figure who is really in
many ways at the heart of the problems
in salem village he certainly does
nothing to improve the situation
and of course the story of salem village
and reverend paris is probably most
beautifully told by paul boyer and
steven nissenbaum in their really
path-breaking book on the salem witch
trials published in 1974 salem possessed
and uh here's actually a rare photograph
you see this actually from the dust
jacket when they were young young
academic pups young young turks and
historians going out to conquer the
world publishing really a path-breaking
book in american history
where they really look at the minutia in
salem village and the political
social religious conflict in the
community
but having said that with al with all
due respect to this these authors in
this amazing book
the witch trials were so much more than
salem village
in fact one of those facts that people
don't seem to realize is that there were
more people from neighboring andover
accused of witchcraft than they were
from either salem or salem village
so this is a broader issue it isn't just
salem village though admittedly salem is
the epicenter of of the witch trials but
they spread out rapidly from there why
do they do that again it's because of
all of these other factors including
colony-wide political instability
this goes back to the early 1680s when
massachusetts bay loses its treasured
charter the charter of 1629 which grants
them essentially self-government and
also the right to run as a puritan
colony
to make massachusetts bay a unique
religious place
a place for the true believers the
puritan saints and honestly really for
no one else right this is really
religious freedom for them
when they lose this charter and it's
revoked in 1684 the trouble begins
we have the following
several years of turmoil the dominion of
new england under colonel edmund andros
almost a military-like rule if you will
where citizens lose their freedoms uh
where uh toleration of faiths is
enforced which
we think is great but the puritans we're
not big fans of
to the point where andros of course is
overthrown and he's replaced by the
interim government by the old government
of simon bradstreet which is weak and
ineffective and trying to fight off a
new war and meanwhile early in 1692
people hear of the coming of governor
william phipps
from
england with a new charter and almost
the day that he arrives is the day that
the afflictions begin to grow and
multiply in salem village because people
are nervous about what this all means
and all of these things are seen as
signs
by puritans as a sign of god's
displeasure
everything in the 17th century is a sign
of god's pleasure or displeasure in an
age before science and an age before
reason
so in many ways too these are all seen
part of a feeling of spiritual decline
in the colony
and the idea that something is truly
wrong
so briefly let's talk about
puritan declension as it's known puritan
decline
uh and i i won't i won't spend too much
time with some of these these themes
from the great perry miller and other
puritan historians but essentially
there is this thought going on in
massachusetts in the second half of the
17th century that they had strayed from
that puritan experiment they they had
left that straight and narrow path and
that the colony was heading to to ruin
um there are shrieking shrinking numbers
of church membership fewer people
willing to join the church everybody
must attend worship but only the elect
those saints are members of the church
the church is a is a spiritual body of
people it is not a building in new
england in the 17th century and fewer
and fewer members of the second and
third generation are joining
there's an increasingly wealth and
worldliness in massachusetts bay to some
degrees the colony is a victim of its
own success being an important economic
engine in the growing atlantic economy
where the lumber and fish from new
england has shipped into the atlantic
world on ships built here and is part of
that economy that brings riches to new
england oh yes it also too is deeply
embedded in the whole slave system as
well
there are perceived threats from
outsiders particularly quakers and other
religious groups who are coming into the
colony and we could spend the whole day
talking about quakers if this is my my
grad course we'll talk a whole week
probably about the quakers and some of
these other threats that seem crazy to
us but to the puritans were all too real
there were more taverns generally and
less bible reading in the colony
and the ministers were preaching those
fire and brimstone jeremiah sermons
saying that god is coming and he is
terribly angry and he is going to seek
vengeance and now is the time for moral
reformation before it is too late
because satan is in our midst he has
been unleashed by god and it is up to us
to fight back
now i think it's evidence of this the
spiritual turmoil in in 1692
recognize that there are five ministers
who are
at least cried out upon for witchcraft
only one of them has charges formally
lodged against him of course it's george
burroughs who's executed
but
there are far more who are
cried out upon informally accused four
other ministers and in total there are
50 ministers and members of their
extended and close family who are cried
out upon for witchcraft were formerly
accused in 1692. that's almost a third
of the people accused
by the way most of these ministers and
their families are ministers who've
accepted the halfway covenant which
again some puritan hardliners see as a
watering down part of the problem in the
colony i won't dwell on it now but the
point is people were really spiritually
in turmoil and upset and angry and to
some degrees they were unhappy with
their ministers and the authorities and
the politicians were ruling the colony
in 1692 and you see that in those
patterns of accusation
to make it worse economic factors and
military factors are are adding to to
the the downfall of the colony and again
seeing the signs of god's displeasure we
are talking about the worst weather of
the little ice age and that doesn't
necessarily mean the the coldest it
means the most extreme rapid changes
hot dry summers horrible lethal winters
with late frost in the spring early for
us in the fall crop destruction famine
storms of biblical proportions right
frankly we now like we know today
climate change isn't just weather
getting colder or warmer it is extremes
and that's exactly what has happened and
as wolfgang behringer the great european
uh witchcraft historian has noted it's
when you have these extreme fluctuations
in weather and bad weather and famine
yeah that's when you have witch hunts
right
so remember that as we think about the
extreme fluctuations and whether we see
today where are our witch hunts right
so
there's also a military disaster going
on at the same time a horrible war on
the frontier uh
where the
english puritans are losing to the
french and the native americans in a war
that will become known as king williams
war right
and it's not just a a military and
political struggle but it's cast in
religious terms because the french are
catholic the hated enemies of the
puritan and they're alive with native
americans who for the most part are
pagan
or might have converted to catholicism
so it seems like the agents of satan
pardon me but in this way the puritans
would have seen it right the french and
the native americans are allied together
and are going to destroy the puritan
experiment
and those attacks take place in the 60s
and 90s as close as billerica as close
as haverhill as close as andover right
the salem village was perched on the
edge of this frontier it's hard for us
to imagine that the the liberty tree
mall in the north shore mall being on
the cutting edge of the frontier
right but they were
once you get west of route 128 watch out
as someone from fitchburg i can endorse
that sentiment as well
so
the result of all this is is inflation
high taxes economic failure and
a lot of really scared angry people
so how does this translate into
afflictions and accusations in
witchcraft well again it's really
complicated and if you want the the
semester-long version of it you're not
going to get that here today but we'll
just touch on a few sort of salient
points as to what we think might have
led to this but again it's a perfect
storm it's lots of different factors and
we're not entirely sure the the most
important answer is uh what was wrong
with people was
they were bewitched
the good 17th century medical
explanation was these people were
bewitched and it's really hard for us to
wrap our heads around that and to accept
it but remember witchcraft was real in
the 17th century everybody learned
theologians university presidents
governors kings emperors all knew
witchcraft was real
the tough part was how do you prove
someone's a witch all right that's the
tough part
so
i really think and
again by the way i'm not the first to
come up with this pretty much most of
what i'm talking about here today has
been said at one time or another by the
legions of really talented witchcraft
historians who studied this uh people
like boyer and nissenbaum john demos
mary beth norton and i could just spend
the next hour just talking about the
different works
one cliff clear factor seems to be uh
what is now known as mass conversion
disorder which traditionally would have
been known as mass hysteria which is a
term that really is out of fashion for a
number of reasons not the least of which
is that it's gendered
um mass conversion disorder is
controversial hard to diagnose even
today so it's really hard to play
psychiatrist which i'm not looking at
people 300 years ago right but here's
the thing
you understand what mass conversion
order is
it is your mind that is so stressed and
in so much turmoil that your mind
unbeknownst to your body literally
converts that stress into physical
symptoms
right
we are not talking about people acting
out
we are not talking about people faking
their symptoms we are talking about
people who are terrified because they
don't understand why their bodies are
doing what they are doing why they are
shrieking why they are wailing why they
are going deaf dumb blind
and
not knowing unfortunately makes this
worse because it makes you more worried
gives you more mental anguish and so on
now interestingly doctors now know that
the most prevalent population by far
are uh adolescent and teenage girls
um at least 70 80 percent of the victims
of mass conversion disorder having two
daughters who now made it safely into
their 20s i can say
i can relate to this
i would not want to be a teenage girl in
america today and i can imagine it must
have been much worse in the 17th century
in the very stern patriarchal society
that massachusetts bay was like um
interestingly enough mass conversion
disorder usually starts with high status
teenage girls a
very famous case a few years ago in
leroy new york it started out with
cheerleaders who in any high school are
usually at or near the top of the
pecking order right
in 1692 who are the first to become
afflicted it's the niece and daughter of
reverend paris who live in the parsonage
with him he is the most important man in
the colony so his daughters are in
somewhere in the town i mean so his
daughters are the really kind of the
most important kids in the village they
have the highest status so it's not
surprising that they might be the ones
to suffer from this particularly when
your angry father is marching around
storming around the parsonage giving
these fire and brimstone sermons being
convinced that satan is in his midst
literally terrifying his children to
death having no intention to do so right
so i think that explains at least some
of the initial
folks who are afflicted in 1692
but
to the broader point there are a lot of
people who make accusations in 1692
and who are
accused and i want to at least point out
that witchcraft as many of you know is a
gendered crime right uh
historically about 75 percent of people
accused of witchcraft throughout history
have been women
and it's an even higher percentage of
that and salem is a little bit higher
it's 76 that's about the average
there's even a stronger correlation to
women though when you realize
that most of the men who are accused of
witchcraft are family members
relatives friends or defenders of women
who are accused of witchcraft
and in fact in 1692
again the overwhelming majority of
people who are who are
afflicted
are
women mostly this idea of these the
girls the afflicted girls but it's more
than that of course because
frankly most of them are teenagers some
of them are in their early 20s
there are also a couple of adult women
in their late 30s early 40s
and also at least two men john indian
the slave of reverend paris
and interestingly enough judge jonathan
corwin's son
and there's an actual really odd
pre-trial hearing where judge hathorn is
saying uh to to uh one of the afflicted
or one of the accused uh why did you uh
why did you afflict judge corwin's son
so that sort of tells you a little
different legal situation we had in in
1692. um
but having said that too that's just the
things you that you see you know on the
specials on salem with the girls
writhing on the floor which is frankly
really a bit over over dramatic uh in
fact most of the accusations in salem
1692 were more traditional accusations
of witchcraft by men by women from
throughout throughout the community
testifying to uh the use of of of
puppets and and image magic a
preternatural knowledge the ability to
harm people causing livestock to die
causing cows to stop producing milk kind
of more run-of-the-mill things rather
than
signing a covenant with satan and
killing people with his magic right
um
so just really that the affliction and
the afflicted girls
weren't just girls and the people who
were making accusations in salem you
know what i think it's close to 200
people who end up making some kind of
complaint or testify in some way in
salem in 1692. so again it is sort of a
broad circle and again people have lots
of things to complain about
but focusing in on those those afflicted
young ladies
they for the most part led very tough
stressful lives
late teenagers
early 20s
many of them are household servants
uh
quite a few of them were war refugees
from that war that's taken place on the
on the northern frontier in maine in new
hampshire
some of them have orphans or at least
lost one parent so they've suffered a
lot of trauma in their family
and you can see where this would put
them not in the best frame of mind right
the example i like to talk about that we
all like to talk about is mercy short
she's taken captive on the salmon falls
rate of 1690 which destroys present-day
berwick in south berwick maine her
parents are killed on their raid by
native americans in in the french on the
raid
she and some other neighborhood kids are
marched north to quebec she's forced to
convert to catholicism and then
eventually she'll be redeemed and will
be afflicted by witchcraft
and when she
is counseled by cotton mather the young
prominent minister in boston to try to
heal her of her grievous afflictions
she uh she says that she is has in fact
uh i've been
uh tempted by satan who's in the shape
of a tawny man like an indian right
uh and clearly when she she basically is
reliving these moments when her life had
been almost destroyed when she lost
everything that she knew and mercy short
is
a classic case now we know what we would
consider post-traumatic stress disorder
frankly i think anybody who lived on the
frontier in this time period probably
suffered it the rest of their lives um
so there's another another factor that
comes into play and particularly too and
i think many of these these uh many of
these the afflicted girls were were
traumatized in one way or another if you
look closely at the the testimony in
1692 it seems pretty clear to me
that they've gone through verbal if not
physical abuse
and yes i think you might even be able
to make the case to at least suggest
that sexual abuse was possible in at
least one case impossible we will never
be able to prove it
but
the evidence is is kind of tantalizing
if you look at the men
who are accused of witchcraft
most of them have histories of
violence and in fact most of their
specters
their ghosts their spirits that are
afflicting people in 1692 are beating
the afflicted girls
torturing them tormenting them right the
specters so it's not much of a leap that
these specters who are many cases the
masters of these serving girls
are also perhaps carrying out physical
violence against the girls now in 1692
physical violence by a head of the
household husband or for that matter
wife against children or servants not
uncommon um there was more latitude
certainly than there is today
but it sounds like particularly if
you're if you're a teenage servant in a
household you're an orphan or a war
refugee
you probably can't do much to defend
yourself against the attacks of your
unhappy master
not just master but husbands are
problems john willard who was executed
for witchcraft there's testimony in the
salem witch trials to him really
horribly beating his wife
right perhaps one reason why his wife's
family testifies against him
george burrows the famous minister who's
accused and executed for witchcraft
the wives he had he'd lost two two wives
and that's not uncommon that people die
young but his wives ghosts show up and
talk to the afflicted girls and tell
them that george murdered them right
well again george burrows is known for
his tremendous strength and also for his
secretive controlling ways one of his
wives when she tried to write letters to
her brother or her father he censored
them and read them first right
very strange fellow and maybe we're
seeing some some some shades of his
domestic relationship in these
accusations or take giles corey of
course the the famous man who's pressed
to death people have a lot of sympathy
for giles this 80 year old fellow who
was pressed to death personally i don't
have quite so much because giles corey
he was a cantankerous fellow he didn't
deserve to die but he certainly was not
that nice a guy he's accused of setting
of being an arsonist trying to set fire
to his neighbor john proctor's house for
one thing but perhaps his most hideous
offense is in 1675 he
severely beats his young simple-minded
servant to death
a boy named jacob goodell dies a couple
days later and in fact is actually fine
for manslaughter because of it they
couldn't really prove that he murdered
him but he still is fine for it
but people remembered this in 1692 i
assure you and there was an aged goodell
woman who apparently was was afflicted
and said bad things about giles corey
and in 1692 isn't it interesting that
giles cory's apparition beats the girls
with his staff with his basically his
crutch
makes one wonder doesn't about what's
going on and of course perhaps the most
famous from the crucible john proctor
and of course john proctor did not have
a sexual relationship with young 10 year
old abigail williams
she wasn't even the household servant
and margot could tell you at length
about all the problems with the crucible
that it's really not good history even
though it's a wonderful play
but john proctor did have a servant mary
warren she was one of the afflicted and
john was not happy with her afflictions
and he in fact actually he publicly it
admitted to uh threshing the devil out
of her
to stop her afflictions right
and isn't it interesting his specter
threatens mary with hot poker tongues
hot fire tongs
and he himself admits threatening to
burn
the affliction out of her hmm
or take the fact that he calls mary his
jade
um in the 17th century a word not fire
removed shall we say from oh sexual
dalliance or maybe even hooker right not
the term an an aged man whose young wife
is pregnant and has a large family not
the kind of term of endearment one gives
to your serving girl
and
there is this really interesting bit of
testimony where mary is testifying
against proctor and talks about his
spectre and at one point his specter
approaches her
and
mary warren says she she grabs the
specter and pulls this john proctor
specter into her lap
again
can never prove anything there
but it
does make you feel kind of icky and make
you wonder what's going on doesn't it
so
conversion ptsd
abuse war hysteria well clearly that
does not
explain at all
certainly there are some fraudulent
accusations
probably a lot more than we would like
to admit especially from
young people who we would like to think
aren't capable of lying especially when
if you do that you know if you lie that
you're going to be condemned to an
eternity in hell if you're a good
puritan but it clearly clearly happened
um
what didn't cause it well
since i'll just i'll just avoid the
question right up front
no ergot poisoning was not responsible
for the salem witch trials
if you don't know
the idea that was put forward first in
the early 70s and i like would say the
the hippie dippy timothy leary lsd
1970s i could should could stop there
but
the
the idea of this of uh that there is a
mold a natural mold that can grow on
supplies of rye grain which was used to
make bread in salem village and other
places in new england when this mold
grows if you consume it if you ingest it
it is poisonous and can harm you
well
it one of the side effects of one of
these types of ergot is hallucinogen
hallucinogenic like trips
so they're suggesting that the afflicted
girls were just you know having a bad
trip
um well there's a number of problems
with this and this theory which you know
it's like a vampire refuses to die even
if you drive a stake through its heart
uh
it keeps on coming back even though it
was debunked within weeks of when that
first came out and has been regularly
debunked by psychiatrists by mds by
scholars ever since here's the basic
problem i mean first off the problem
with their gut is we're looking for a
simple solution folks our society likes
to take that please doctor can you give
you give me one pill that'll cure all of
my ills oh and by the way they would
also cure everything that's wrong with
society in my life as well right
unfortunately life isn't that simple i
wish it were i really wish it were
and history isn't that simple either
right um
the problem with ergot first off from
from a grain supply point of view
um
not all the afflicted girls live in the
same place they live miles apart some of
the afflicted live in andover there are
people who are afflicted like mercy
short in boston i've already mentioned
so we're not talking about one bad grain
supply right and also if everyone in the
village is eating from that one bad
grain supply why isn't everybody
becoming afflicted why is it only like
maybe one maybe two members of a family
so
it doesn't make any sense from a pattern
there at all because again these are
accusations and charges that are made
throughout much of massachusetts bay
colony
but beyond that
the doctors tell us that there are
different types of ergot and there's one
like sort of necrotizing more like
well let's just put it this way the type
this type of ergot
uh
uh the only type of ergot that causes
hallucinogenic side effects uh is
basically like a dry rot or a dry
gangrene where your arms and legs your
limbs shrivel blacken fall off and then
you die
no one described anything like this in
1692
as far as we can tell strange as it may
sound most of the afflicted girls appear
to have led long healthy
normal lives maybe we don't know much
about them but certainly uh no one
walking around as quadruple amputees
would be kind of weird to walk around
never mind anyhow um didn't mean that
but uh you get what i'm talking about
it's absolutely absolutely does it just
doesn't work
and frankly no i don't believe in
encephalitis lyme disease or a lot of
these other sort of medical conditions
is it possible that one or two people
had some one of these conditions yes
absolutely again 17th century medicine
is different than today but it certainly
doesn't explain the whole outbreak
the other thing that i want to say too
is that most people ask is but it was to
get their land wasn't it weren't people
accused in 1692 by their neighbors who
were jealous my friends and people who
wanted their land wanted their property
because if you accuse someone of
witchcraft you got their stuff
sounds good but not true
there is a as with most things there's a
kernel of truth there uh in 1692 for the
one time in massachusetts history for
reasons i won't go into here but legal
reasons is regarding the new charter
uh massachusetts reverted to english law
which included the provision that
a felon's personal possessions were
seized became property of the state that
includes your clothes your cash your
livestock
furniture
but
houses
real estate all land
goes to your heirs if you are executed
for a high crime
so you never lose your property
and
even if your personal possessions are
taken
yeah i guess what folks then now the
state wins the government is the
recipient of uh of your property no one
else there's no finders fee no nothing
that doesn't mean to say that jealous
neighbors didn't accuse people of
witchcraft but it was not to
profit right
so let's shoot that one down
to me though again i really sort of
generations of historians have viewed
the salem witch trials in large part
as
a social crime and most of the stories
going back to boyer and nissenbaum uh
and others who've looked at witchcraft
traditionally have been social
historians you know i was i was uh
actually inspired by these people and
was a a young new social historian in
the 1970s uh now i guess you know sort
of like the old social history which is
now kind of morphed into the the
cultural history which is actually now
kind of becoming i think maybe the old
cultural history
be that as it may
most historians studying witchcraft in
america have looked at it as the social
crime of neighbor accusing neighbor or
like john demos kind of looking at the
psychology behind those accusations and
the tensions in the in the community um
but to me i really in my book i really
wanted to look at the judges now maybe
this is the fact that i'm the first
member of my family born since the civil
war not to join the family law firm out
in fitchburg
but
sort of that lawyer want to be um
but i really thought that hadn't been
explored because but to me it was the
critical question was you can have as
many people accuse people of witchcraft
as possible you can have juries convict
them either even why do judges sane
rational english judge justices working
under english law
that frankly isn't all that different
than what we have today
right basic forms of of testimony
witnesses yes a few irregularities like
you're not going to hear testimony when
your son's afflicted by the person who
might have afflicted him but still
pretty good english justice usually
pretty fair english justice where you
were innocent until proven guilty why do
these judges experienced men who've all
for the most part seen witchcraft cases
before
why are they accepting convictions and
signing death warrants that was the
piece to me that i was interested in
that's why i say i like to study this as
a political crime and as a political
crisis as much as anything else
recognizing that that political crisis
in hand in hand in a puritan colony with
religion as well
so i was intrigued to look at the judges
and try to figure out why they turned
legal precedent on its head
and by that i mean before 1692
if you were confe if you confessed to
witchcraft
and by the way that's usually after
judicial torture
you were executed
we know that judicial torture was used
in salem even john proctor writes to the
ministers complaining that his sons
and the carrier boys are being
tied neck and heels
that is your
your heels are tied to your neck and
you're hung upside down
head down until basically blood gushes
out of your nose
it won't kill you
but you know what you think it will
so in some ways i consider the 17th
century equivalent of waterboarding
right
and also loosens the tongue
good god maybe okay yes maybe i am a
witch after all you're right let's
reconsider this
there was some of this going on in salem
in 1692. and usually traditionally what
happened after that was
right
trial confessed
sentence
execution within days
so explain to me why in 1692 only those
who refuse to confess
are convicted and executed
there are a few at the end who confess
who are tried and convicted
at the very end but for the most part
we're talking about people who plead
innocent
and are eventually led to their deaths
that's because of it and meanwhile 55
people that's about over a third of the
people who were accused
confess
none of them die
that to me is the ultimate
tragedy of salem the fact that only
those who were so devout that they
refused to lie and say that they were a
witch because they knew it would be a
stain on their immortal soul a stain on
their family they refused to do it
only the truly truly innocent died
and that is the ultimate tragedy of
bridget bishop and everyone else
so
why
why would the judges do this well
the nine judges i started looking at
closely and they have a lot in common
they are the wealthiest merchants in the
colony they are members of the
governor's council hand-picked by the
king to do so
so that means they're the leading
politicians in the land today what we
call the state senate
they're also superior court judges by
definition of that appointment and
county judges
a majority of them had attended harvard
at one point trained to be ministers as
well so these are learned men
yet in 1692 none of them have followed
that path
they are major land holders of frontier
lands sawmill owners on the main
frontier where most of them have had
their sawmills burn and they've lost
what would today be equivalent to
millions of dollars in investments
they are the military leaders of the
colony by the way too
most of them are officers in the militia
judge waite winthrop the grandson of the
great john winthrop of city upon the
hill fame he's actually a witchcraft
judge and at the same time is commander
in chief of the massachusetts army that
is badly losing the struggle against the
french and the native americans
so
here's the thing
these men these devout puritans who are
also calling for moral reformation
throughout the colony
have to be looking for someone to blame
for the events of 1692.
let's blame the government oh wait
that's us
let's blame the military
that's us too
as dana carvey says
could it be satan
you know here's the problem and we
if you think about it i mean on the
surface it's funny um
but really human nature is it's a lot
easier for us to look away look outside
to find uh to find the guilty to find
the blame for our problems rather than
to look within right and unfortunately
these judges are seeing witches
everywhere they know that satan has been
set loose in the colony by all the
things that have gone wrong and got to
the colony and to them personally and
they are hanging judges now intriguingly
enough
they're also family
in my research i determined that six of
the nine
are actually all related by marriage
interestingly enough the one of the ones
who isn't samuel sewell
maybe the most honest man of the crowd
the one that i really admire he's
actually turns out his wife is the first
cousin of reverend samuel paris of salem
village
uh another interesting link so clearly
these are these are a group they act
together they're deferential towards
each other and when william stoughton
leads the way and says guilty there's
not going to be any dissent because
these people have the same family class
personal business political military
interests right
so it's these conditions that make the
judges presume guilt from the start that
satan is loose in massachusetts and you
have to look no further than the first
day of pre-trial hearings when judges
haythorne and corwin
should be sort of like the halderman and
ehrlichman of 1692.
um
question sarah good
and judge haythorne asks her what evil
spirits have you familiarity with have
you made no contract with the devil
why do you harm these children
it doesn't sound like an english system
of justice i'd want to be a part of
right and that's the point in other
years it wouldn't have been like this
the judge there were no lawyers in
massachusetts in 1692 they were actually
outlawed until the early 18th century um
the judges really acted as prosecution
and defense attorney trying to ferret
out the truth
and normally that worked well but in
this case as you can see
something had already gone badly awry
and it was this whole storm
of witchcraft this perfect storm of
factors that really even threw the
judges off of their normal behavior many
of these judges had been involved in
witchcraft cases in the 1680s that had
been dismissed
but things had changed in massachusetts
so
lastly though
i'll come back to the scene again these
are all sort of issues of religion and
politics right
and that means we really need to look
at the leadership
so
imagine if you
will in a
far off time in a distant galaxy
a powerful political leader who comes to
office
lacking any political experience
whatsoever
as a young man he comes to the big city
to the economic center of the universe
to make his fortune
he becomes one of the richest men in
america by taking big risks
winning and losing
making deals breaking deals
incredibly famous huge personality
larger than life
he has a late conversion to his
political cause
only shortly before seeking high office
makes many members of his party
suspicious at his motives
but he champions the cause of the
working class as an incredibly popular
for that and that helps really launch
him to office
once in office his style
immediately makes people nervous even
before he takes office when they know of
his coming office
partly because he's an unconventional
communicator
he doesn't really play by the rules
and in fact
because of that he quickly almost
immediately gets himself embroiled in
legal issues
he shows irrational support for the
mortal enemies of the
state which also scares people
not surprisingly
as wolfgang behringer would point out
when you have weak central states lots
of questions about authority
you have the cry of witch hunt
people are worried people are looking
for witches
now by this time i know you all realize
who i'm talking about i'm speaking of
sir william phipps
the governor of the massachusetts bay
colony who was announced in january 1692
at which point the afflictions begin
because people are terrified in part
about him
and arrives in may 1692 with the
afflictions full blown
i happen to sir william really well
i co-authored the biography of him with
my buddy john reed a number of years ago
and that's actually where i first got
sort of drawn into salem's web because
the whole book could have been about
witchcraft
sir william was the first to salvage a
spanish treasure galleon he's actually
the patron saint of treasure hunters
became uh immediately famous and grew
developed a fortune through this it was
his it was his second try to do this
again he basically went belly up before
this trying to do it so he was a
survivor but when he does he goes back
to england he's knighted by the king
he's the first englishman to be knighted
by the king of england or the american
englishman that is to be knighted by the
king of england he comes back to
massachusetts bay he is arguably the
most famous
englishman in america and he could have
probably didn't have to come back he
could have stayed in england the rest of
his life and every night someone would
have bought him dinner in a pint of veil
to hear his stories he was that famous
right he was that wealthy too
he comes home in 1692 as the first royal
governor of massachusetts bay under a
new charter
and after that
the trouble begins
that makes him of course governor during
the salem witch trials
he ends them
only after 19 are dead
and
really only after his wife is accused of
being a witch
about that time he writes a letter back
to the crown
and he says basically says
gosh you know this is horrible i was off
all summer and fall fighting against the
french and the indians in maine when i
came back i saw the horrible things
deputy governor stoughton had done and i
was mortified and i brought it to an end
immediately
liar liar pants on fire
he was in the colony almost all of that
time
fake news
he knew exactly what was going on
and was covering
covering himself as best he could
um
he gets into a mess with the french
one of his successes as a military man
in 1690 actually briefly he invades
leads an expedition for massachusetts
that invades port royal invades
acadia and captures it they don't have
enough people to really occupy the
territory so instead he he swears all
the french there to an oath of loyalty
to the english king
and phipps thinks it's real
and when he's governor in 1692
um he defends the french and acadia he
welcomes them as merchants and traders
to this to the to the to the waterfront
of boston
and other people kind of go like really
sir william
really we're at war with these people
really
and in fact he runs across the scene one
day on the waterfront in boston
where uh one of these uh french acadian
merchants has been given a hard time by
the bostonians and the customs officials
and phipps who was known for his
very open sometimes even vulgar
expressions
and and bare knuckle street politics
basically says hey wait a second this
man is a good an englishman as you are
and i'll basically beat you if you don't
leave him alone
the irony is we now know that that man
was actually a french spy
and he was gathering information for
planned invasion of new england in
boston right
throughout his career in as governor
phipps is dogged by charges of
misbehavior
fellow was actually borderline only
borderline literate as far as we can
tell
and in 1694 he'll be recalled to england
to answer for alleged high crimes uh as
as governor um a lot of stuff trumped up
but just an also a lot of stuff that
we'll never quite get to the bottom of
because unfortunately he dies in london
of illness before he can defend himself
before the before the king so rather a
sad story to a rather interesting
character but i just can't help reflect
on on william phipps these days
so in
conclusion
how could they be so dumb people always
ask me this how could they believe in
witches how could they execute 19
innocent people
well here's the problem folks as i said
witches were all too real in 1692
and their goal was to destroy
our faith our society
and
the problem is
it is almost impossible to detect them
right
increase mather the leading minister of
the colony the top political aid
interesting combination to governor
phipps
no division of church and state back
then folks that's another thing that
begins to happen after 1692. people say
maybe the governor's top aides shouldn't
be the ministers
maybe we need some space there
increase matthew ends up writing a book
calling really for an end to the witch
trials and he entity says you know it's
really hard to tell if someone's a witch
or not
legally there's only two ways you can
technically convict people of witchcraft
signed confession
or the testimony of two people saying
that they have seen someone carry out a
malfeasant act of black magic in league
with
satan since we all agree i hope that
that's not real
it's hard to get people to testify to
that right
so instead they start trying to lean on
other evidence because you know
satan's got to be here somewhere right
and that's where we start looking at
things like spectral evidence right
those those spirits of people harming
people and the over reliance on that in
salem and finally increased mather says
you know what
enough is enough
people can't say this too loudly but by
the fall of 1692 it's clear that at
least some innocent people have been
imprisoned if not executed right
you can't say that because that'll bring
down the whole state the whole colony if
you do but it's becoming painfully clear
that this has happened so increased
mather just puts it this way he says
better
that a hundred witches should live
then one innocent person should die
right
yes there are probably witches out there
we're never gonna be able to figure out
who they are
because they're almost impossible to
detect witches can be anyone family
friends loved ones neighbors heck
ministers i mentioned all those
ministers and their families who are
accused mentioned several members of the
general court the massachusetts
legislature who were accused
people didn't trust their politicians
didn't trust their ministers they were
angry they were scared anybody could be
a witch right
well what do you do
how do you how do you fight this this
invisible threat this invisible world
how do you stop them well i think we
know the answer folks
if you swap witches in 1692 with
terrorists today
you really probably understand the
problem
and realize how really difficult it is
to try to deal with a a threat that we
all know is alive and well
and threatens us at the roots of
everything we believe in
but how do we do it and particularly how
do we do it without giving up those
cherished english liberties
right
it's it's to me it's the big issue that
we have to deal with as a society today
but of course
we don't believe in witches or witch
hunts do we
thank you very much
now um
i think i have
maybe five ten minutes
to answer any questions i'm going to be
here all day so i'll be glad to take
them if anyone who asked them charlie if
you want to go up and use the microphone
so that you your voice can be heard
with my voice all right
what was the population
okay
question was what was the population of
salem at that time um
salem village danvers had maybe five or
600 people in it
the population of salem town itself here
sort of the neck
the rest of the community maybe a couple
thousand so you're dealing with a
population roughly very roughly about
2500 people which again if you think
about that population density is is
ridiculously low by our modern standards
yep other questions
yeah
hang on here there's the mic right
coming right to you don't be shy okay
so i read that some of the
folks who were accused were finally
pardoned in the 50s and others in like
2001 why did it take so long
good question the actual the the first
pardons were in the early 1700s and
there was a was called technically a
reversal of attainder uh in 1711 a
general reversal of attainder against uh
most of the people but those
laws when they were put through only
applied to those families
who had requested them
um
and so there were a lot of people who
did not maybe didn't have a lot of close
loved ones or had been alienated from
their families and families were not
willing to come forward and requested
their names be exonerated
um so in fact there was another round in
the 1950s
uh where uh a man who was actually um a
relative a descendant of and putator uh
made a request that the remaining
witches if you will again quotes have
their retainers reversed um and the the
the document said uh ann predator and
others
and um
my uh one of my uh former grad students
paula keane in my witchcraft class said
followed a footnote in bernie rosenthal
salem story said professor baker look at
this i don't think those other people by
massachusetts law your name has to be
mentioned
by name for it to count and i don't
think there's five people who haven't
been have the reversal attained what do
you think he said should i try to do
something about it you know should i i
said i'm very famous paula reminds me
every time said i said well crazier
things have happened but paula launched
a one-woman campaign and those you know
know what a remarkable woman she is
where she um
got our legislature involved got our got
our our delegates involved and actually
got the last reversal of attainder which
was signed
uh
on halloween
2001 by by governor swift and i applaud
governor swift for doing it i just wish
he hadn't come to salem on halloween to
do it because as we all know there are
no connections between witchcraft and
halloween but so that's why it took so
long at the enlarged part people sort of
thought they had
but even then it took almost 20 years to
get most of the attainers reversed yeah
other questions
great
thank you all very much